hey what's up guys it's Marquez from the
mkbhd YouTube channel back with another
HD video of the Chrome Web Store now I
know you don't have to search through it
using Google Voice Search but I figured
I'd show you guys you can do that with
chrome also anyway but go ahead and hit
the new tab page in chrome and you'll
also have the option to visit it right
here along with the other app shortcuts
but here is the brand new overview of
the Chrome Web Store it is looking
really really good you can click on the
link in the description to check it out
yourself up here you have a preview of
all the most popular apps or the
featured ones and if you scroll down you
have all the panes with the the icons if
you will of the less popular apps but
all the rest of the apps that are
featured here on the home page these are
all the best of the best applications so
you can see some of these are larger and
some of those are smaller thumbnails
just like in Google+ and if you go ahead
and hover over one of them you'll have
the option to add it to Chrome
immediately or click on it and use a
little pane where you can view all the
information about the app so here you
can give it a +1 on Google+ if you want
to add me on Google+ that's in the
description too you can add it to Chrome
directly if you have screenshots and
even view a YouTube video that the
company may have chosen to embed and you
can view the details of the app of
course they can add all that kind of
stuff to their website and all the user
reviews you can leave your review too if
you install an application so that's
very helpful go ahead and exit out of
that here if you see one of the larger
panels you can go directly to the right
to view screenshots of that app so all
the featured apps that are have these
massive panels here you can view
screenshots of them just by clicking the
right and left arrows so that's pretty
convenient also you notice my scroll
ball is tiny that's because you can
scroll infinitely through applications
infinite scrolling through as many apps
as you want and eventually at a certain
point it gets to these smaller panes I
think you have to scroll for quite a
while though here you go so now you have
only smaller panes for all the apps but
you still get to go through infinite
scroll which is really convenient if you
just want to waste time in the Chrome
Web Store over on the left is of course
your search and all your categories this
can also there are paid apps here but
you can also get some extensions so
there's extension categories there's
social and communication
there's fun there's news and weather
extensions things like that and once you
sort by category it gives you a whole
new page again large panes and small
panes so here's a whole bunch of
different screen shots of bouncy mouse
you can add it to Chrome immediately or
check out these other applications here
I'm gonna go ahead and search for an app
I'm gonna search for a weather app even
though there's a weather category I'll
search for weather and you can see this
is what it looks like when you search
through apps again this is I love the
redesigns that Google is putting through
all their web apps it's really looking
good hit the collections button over
here and you have a whole bunch of
collections of applications so let's say
a money collection that's a pretty sweet
collection of apps right there Google
finance finance 41 a bunch of great apps
I think you guys should check out the
Chrome Web Store it is looking really
good and if you enjoyed this video go
ahead and give it a thumbs up I'm gonna
let you guys go ahead and make sure you
have the latest version of Chrome and
get to exploring it yourself so thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you guys
later peace
you